this is the showstopper when these
souffles come out of this oven and they
go in the dining room you're gonna hear
silence across that room because they're
gonna go WOW now I'm going to show you
dessert this is called panna cotta we've
got the passion fruits make sure to
squash the seeds mango icing sugar
orange whisk away it's really good now
how did you come up with this recipe
I've been cooking for 30 [ __ ] news
Terry what you in the bars were you at
home I asked kids each the oven for
minutes now quenelle hot spoon in and
curve and that's gonna get dropped into
the souffle am I really cure take it off
the heat we got in with a cream in there
are we gonna put the vanilla seeds sugar
boil then orange zest as soon as starts
to bubble then we put in the gelatin and
then these go straight on yeah look look
quickly quickly start the top in and out
ibaka now Larry you missed the hole that
is amazing this is so good three hours
in the fridge job is done
and I'm gonna show you what they look
like and we're gonna put this on here
now look at this crunchy biscuit for
texture this what it should look like
come on let's do it let's go let's do
this okay I'm gonna show you it right
that's it right that is it all right
let's go please speed dial that's one
name
hi Helen it's me Jerry knew to sort of
words your son or Denise you'll get a
little bit chippy can you just like
telling tripping down who's the [ __ ]
chauffeur come on big day tomorrow
do it worries beautiful that's beautiful
I am flourishing I can cook that is
thanks to my amazing team and I have got
great teacher in Gino I'm definitely on
the right team all right
what are you then brilliant
Bravo did you place ready eyes you sugar
out in the next we've got the next bit
yeah don't just talk to me garden
another strop tell me that you made him
cry please there's ninety eight more
suitcase to go it's gonna be right I
promise it's Gordon upstair that she
called his mum after my pal it's good a
tough day Stephens got it Larry ends up
last but always on point with flavor and
Jerry well Jerry's just the confirmed
[ __ ] nut job it's like a 20-18
version of One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest yeah
I'm being taught by an absolute master
so you get completely caught up in it
with his enthusiasm and that is the sign
of an amazing teacher junior Gordon is
gonna be 100% in the [ __ ]
tomorrow with these men you definitely
set the bar too high